first I want to say congratulations to
all the winners this is a great
accomplishment one that will change your
lives forever honestly you should be
very very proud I'm honored to present
the gold silver and bronze prizes for
documentary it's a genre that I have
great respect for having had the
opportunity to do several myself I
appreciate your passion documentary
films are important visual essays that
present historical subjects current
social and political issues or simply
observe the human experience when done
right they have a lasting dramatic
impact leaving the audience better
informed and moved and the fact that you
are sitting here tonight is a testament
that you did in fact do it right from
the 73 documentary entries this year the
three winning films are the Apothecary
by Helen hood shear from Stanford
University in California in a dying
mining town a beloved pharmacist
faithfully served his struggling
community as he deals with his own
personal self doubts one child by Z Jen
moon from New York University is about
the 2008 see chew on earthquake that
killed more than 5,000 children it
examines the emotionally devastating
effect on three families living under
China's one-child policy in White Earth
by Jay Christian Jensen from Stanford
University in California we witnessed
the hardships and challenges of everyday
life in North Dakota and North Dakota
North Dakota oil fields as seen through
the eyes of children and an immigrant
family